[Music]
I'm excited to be here at Google cloud
next talking to you about a topic that
I'm very excited about speech
recognition I hope you're having a great
time here at Google Google cloud next so
you know why do we even have speech
recognition at at Google cloud platform
so you know we started developing speech
recognition at Google more than a decade
ago I think even more than 15 years ago
and we did it for our internal uses for
for web search and then later for our
other apps because we figured that voice
will be you know used very prominently
in our apps but you know we never
intended to offer it to third parties as
a commercial service and that changed
last year and the reason why that
changed was you know we went through a
big revolution at Google with machine
learning I'm sure you've heard a lot
about it in our you know keynotes this
year and last year and you know we
really wanted to help other companies
take advantage of machine learning and
benefit the same way that we did and
we're doing that in two different ways
one way is well helping companies build
their own custom machine learning models
and you know anyone can use tensorflow
it's open source you know don't just
download it for free and start using it
right away
sorry or you know we we started offering
in beta in September and yesterday we
announced general availability for a
cloud machine learning engine which lets
anyone use machine learning on the cloud
to develop their own models so that's
very exciting and we think over time
that's gonna enable a lot of new
opportunities different use cases for
businesses but the reality is that most
businesses don't have sort of the
expertise or the resources or the data
that is needed to develop their own
custom
and you know in our aspiration to still
enable people to take advantage of
machine learning we also offer what we
call our machine learning API so ready
to use models that anyone can can just
use as an API as a service that we've
already pre trained and in that set we
have cloud vision cloud speech cloud
jobs cloud translation natural language
api and then yesterday we added one more
to this list which is our new video
intelligence API so so that's how speech
sort of fits into the picture we're very
very excited about speech it's currently
in beta it's about to go VGA very very
soon so you know what is so what is so
exciting about speech speech recognition
people have been doing it for a very
long period of time but it's actually an
inflection point right now so you know
other analysts have said yeah it's it's
it's now the biggest revolution in
human-computer interactions since the
iPhone introduced touch so 10 years ago
and you know it's it's dramatically
changing the way applications are being
developed and and you know will be
developed in the future voice is you
know faster easier more convenient in
many ways than typing or navigating
through menus and so we're seeing you
know just just in the last year an
explosion of voice apps but in the
future we're going to see even more of
it you know today more than 20% of our
Android app searches are already voice
you know and we're very excited about
that we you know we we want to make it
as easy as possible to use all of our
services as you know which you're all
app developers are out there so in terms
of the kind of broader landscape for
speech recognition you know what is it
good for we kind of see it in in two
broad themes one is around
human-computer interaction we just
talked about so that
as things like voice search for its
actions messaging dictation you know
this is fueling different surfaces like
mobile apps web apps connected devices
and to a lesser extent also phone
directed apps and basically enabling a
new way for humans to interact with
systems the other kind of big domain is
speech analytics and this is fairly new
we're just starting to see this come out
in a big way now because the technology
is starting to be big enough and that
could be you know call center analytics
video analytics messaging meaning
analytics basically taking speech that
is already happening in our world today
and generating new insights from it so
I'm gonna show you later
a bunch of different demos more centered
around the domain on the left on
human-computer interaction and I'm gonna
invite our guest speaker Gary who's
gonna show you how they implemented a
very interesting use case on the right
hand side on call center analytics so
you know it's gonna be it's gonna be a
fun session we're also going to do a
kind of a crazy code lab I'm gonna try
and you know write an app in less than
10 minutes that will do speech
recognition sentiment analysis and
translation using Google's API so
hopefully it will work we'll see but
we're gonna do a little bit of that
later okay
so you know what is cloud speech AP API
and why are we so excited about it so
you know it's it's our neural network
based speech recognition we've I already
mentioned before we were making it
available for the first time now and
it's universally available across 80
plus languages in variants basically you
know I think more
more than half of the people that use
smartphones today around the world are
already covered and and we're aiming for
more than that you can use it in two
different modes real-time streaming and
and batch and I'm going to show you a
little bit of both later today and it's
accurate in noisy environments and with
different axes so when we built our
speech recognition we needed it to work
for you know people that are walking
around in Times Square
walking on with their phones and asking
their phone what's the weather like in
New York while there's a hundred other
people right next to them
and so it knows how to filter background
voices but there's also people in India
that are walking the screen and there's
a bus passing right next to them and and
so it knows how to filter kind of all
different kinds of background noises and
focus on the on the primary speaker and
the last thing here I wanted to
emphasize we have a really easy way of
customizing speech to your domain so you
know if you have a name of a company or
a name of a product that's not actually
a word in English or in the language
that you're trying to work in we make it
really easy all you need to do is just
tell us what that word is and we
automatically add it to the dictionary
for you and we can start recognizing it
if you're in a specific mode in your
application where you're expecting a
certain command so if you're building
speech recognition for a player and
you're playing a movie so you might want
to detect stop and pause but then when
you're not playing a movie you might
want to tech play or other words you can
use word and phrase hands to detect
exactly the words you need in the right
context so we have three different
methods for using speech API streaming
sync and async streaming allows you to
process speech in real time while the
user is saying it and so it's it's it's
the fastest way of using speech API
it works with something called G RPC
which is our sort of improved binary
version of rest that your PC people are
gonna kill me for saying that but it's a
it's a it's a faster more efficient
protocol and way of sort of accessing
remote procedures and allows you to
process any audio up to a minute that's
included in line in the request sync is
a much easier to use method any you know
it's a way you can use it on REST API
you can even do it with a curl command
and it's it can process any audio up to
a minute you can either embed the audio
in line or use Google Cloud storage and
and then we have async which allows you
to process larger files it's basically
not limited it says up to 80 minutes but
you know that can be increased if you
get a quota increase and it can also be
accessed by rest and process files
either inline or a Google Cloud storage
so with with async because it's it's not
blocking you can quickly process a large
number of files and then just check back
in to see if they're if they're done
processing in terms of standards if you
know when I wrote this the slide I was
yeah even like I forgot how many
different standards we support it's it's
it's it's pretty Universal that's
something we're very proud of you know
there's a large list of programming
languages you can use to access cloud
speech API and a large list of audio
encoding that we support now this is you
know this is not an experimental project
that someone at Google is running this
you know is is a commercial service that
we're fully backing and you know really
developing investing a lot in so you
know
wanted to give you guys just a little
bit of best practices if you are
developing speech recognition apps you
know what we recommend and and first
first slide is about human-computer
interaction so the left-hand side of the
use cases that we spoke about earlier so
for human-computer interaction you
really want to use streaming whenever
you can you know when you can't use
streaming you can use sync but then
there's gonna be a delay and sort of
users are waiting for a response so it's
it's not recommended you always want to
use uncompressed audio if you can and if
you have if you want to compress you
should use lossless compression because
lossy compression like mp3s or things
like that they really degrade the
accuracy of the recognition you know
ideally want to use a high as high of a
sampling rate as you can but at least
above 16 kilohertz or 16 kilohertz or
more you don't want to go below that if
you if you want to use human-computer
interaction and if you you know if you
if you have a choice if you're not
running on phone phone lines and
whenever you can you want to use speech
context to you know to get the best
accuracy results that you can now using
speech API requires that you specify the
language in advance so what we see a lot
of app developers do is they detect the
language of the OS and that way they
know what language the user is going to
speak and they provide that to cloud
speech API so then there's the other set
of use cases which are speech analytics
so they're you know you're typically
dealing with longer form audio like you
know a call could be 5 minutes 10
minutes 15 minutes a movie could be you
know one hour two hours three hours so
you want to use a sink most probably you
you know you want to store those files
on Google Cloud storage and then process
them in batch and you know if there's if
there's multiple speakers you may want
to separate the
the streams so that you can process
speakers separately if you're processing
a video you you you might want to use a
tool like ffmpeg to strip out the audio
and just send the audio to to class
speech API and it's very easy to combine
it with natural language API and
translation soup API which you're going
to see in a second okay wanted to give
you guys you know a few examples of
human-computer interaction because when
we're going to spend more time later
about the about speech analytic so a
czar is a video chat discovery app does
anyone here in this room know about a
sir okay a few so you know apparently
they have 15 billion discovering matches
already so what what they do is they
they connect people with new people that
they don't know and they've done at 15
billion times already yeah every time I
hear about this I'm just shocked
and most of the time or many times it's
people in different countries that speak
different languages and you know that
it's it's there's a little bit of a
language barrier like you can imagine
when two people from different countries
want to talk to each other so what they
do is they use called speech API to
transcribe the speech into text and then
they use translation API to convert that
from one language to another and they
allow two people in different countries
to talk to each other and they can as
they're talking they see on the screen
what the other person is saying and they
can react to that so it's pretty cool
it's really sort of enabling use cases
that we're not really of possible maybe
even like you know one or two years ago
very very exciting you know another
example is tribe which is a messaging
app they use this video and it allows
people you know that don't want to type
a message they just want to you know say
something to their friends they can
record a quick video
say whatever they want to say and tribe
will show the video Oh
enable adding text to that video by
transcribing the text and all stand and
defining some sort of keywords or alerts
or things like that so if you you know
if you mention a dinner or a restaurant
or something it can sort of react to
that and give the user more information
about what what they're talking about
pretty cool okay
so now I want to show you guys a few
demos can we switch to the to the demo
computer yeah cool so this is always
risky speech recognition demos in a
large room with echo is like yeah not
what it was intended for but what I'm
going to show you now I'm just using a
regular computer and using the mic from
the computer for my computer nothing
special no special equipment I'm just
going to talk close to the computer and
you know let's see let's see what it's
able to do so okay that passed by okay I
think it got a hundred percent I'm not
sure you know usually it gets a hundred
percent or close to it not it doesn't
always get every single word but I think
this time it might have and I don't know
if you guys noticed but while I was
talking you could see on the top the
words were appearing in real time almost
in the exact same moment that I said the
word so you know it's pretty impressive
it's very very fast you know the other
thing I would say is interesting here is
you can see that I said the word meet
twice and even though you pronounced it
in exactly the same way it knows how to
differentiate and from the context of
the sentence it knows when I said you
know this mean and when I said that mean
so I'm this near works I'm I'm always
amazed it's pretty it's pretty cool let
me show you something
I really love Taylor Swift which is true
by the way okay we have a bug in the
demo here but you can see this demo uses
a couple different elements so one is it
combines speech API with natural
language API so you can see the overall
sentiment is positive so it detected
that and it also extracted the entity
Taylor Swift and it brought up a card it
knows it's a singer-songwriter it has a
little bit of a description from
Wikipedia and you can click on the link
but the other thing I wanted to show you
is you know our speech recognition was
built originally for for our search
engine and so you know it's built to
recognize named entities really really
well you know we get searches for every
single entity you could imagine and a
lot of those searches are voice searches
and so we developed our speech
recognition in a way that it knows how
to handle that and when you when you
mention entities with speech we will
detect them even if it's not a word in
English and we will format them so you
can see it's capitalized and it knows
how to recognize the entity so the third
and last demo so this is a demo that
sort of tries to teach you how to speak
a new language with with speech API and
and with with translation API so you
know it's going to detect that I'm in in
an airport and about to fly to Tokyo and
it's gonna try and teach you just nice
did you guys hear that call meet snap
okay it wants it wants me the second is
your Scylla I'll try and get this wrong
and let's see let's see what happens
konnichiwa konnichiwa
okay that way that wasn't wrong enough
let me again give Eska let me try this
one again key Sokka
organ key so apparently what I said in
Japanese is King motto he may soccer so
actually recognized my language in
Japanese and then translated it back
into English so so pretty cool okay so
so you know these are sort of
pre-prepared demos and you'll say okay
that's fine but like you know how easy
is it really to use so what I'm gonna
show you guys you know if you just go to
cloud google.com slash speech you click
on view documentation and you click on
our samples you can see samples for all
the languages that I mentioned earlier
I'm gonna go to the Python sample and
you know you can see there's basically a
Python example here and you know I've
loaded it onto onto my computer and I
recorded this this audio file out I'll
play it for you guys I'm really loving
this session so far it's pretty awesome
I especially like all the code examples
so hopefully that's represented or some
of you if not then maybe a little bit
later and let's try and you know i pre
downloaded this this demo let's try can
you guys see my my terminal maybe make
it bigger better now okay I'm gonna try
and transcribe it
and and let's see what's happening so
it's it's taking this file that I
recorded in a in a library called code
and it's it's sending it to the cloud
and getting a result back so you can see
really loving the session so far it's
pretty awesome I especially like all the
core examples so it kind of got the the
gist of it but now you know what happens
let's say we wanted to add sentiment
analysis to that how do we do that so
I'm going to go to our natural language
page and you know if you just click how
to analyze sentiment and go to Python
there's a code segment here I'm just
going to copy it and add it here to our
Python script and I can just put this up
front here and that's also import from
google doc cloud import language and let
me fix the indentation and now we want
to feed it this text alternative
transcript which is what comes back from
the speech API so let's feed that here
and then we do the sentiment analysis
and then let's print this cor I don't
think we need the magnitude so you can
just find that let me save
let's run it and let's see if it
actually works
so this is um it's it's okay so it
worked - got the transcript and I got
the sentiment score so what do you guys
think about that that was pretty easy
[Applause]
okay so let's make it more complicated
now and let's also add translation and
let's go back to my editor and let's
paste it in here put the client up front
and I'll import the library from Google
the cloud import translate and this here
and now
let's feed it instead of text
let's give it this alternative of
transcript
and instead of target language let's
just give it a es for Spanish and now we
don't really need the text because we
already printed it let's print the
translation okay now let's run it let's
see what happens now when we run it with
the combination of so what it's what it
should be doing now is showing us the
transcript then showing the score and
then showing the translation so that's
it we have it it worked in Spanish and
and with sentiment analysis let's try
one more thing so I wasn't sure if you
guys would really like this so I also
recorded a different option let's play
it I really hate this session so far
it's very boring I can't wait until it's
over okay so let's try and transcribe
that with speech recognition and also
analyze sentiment and translate that and
let's see if that's gonna work so that's
it it worked
[Applause]
so it's it's pretty awesome and you know
this is this is our beta version as I
mentioned we're gonna have our GA
version coming out soon and it's going
to be it's going to be even better you
know I can't go into too much details
but we're very excited about it
so with that let me welcome onto the
stage Gary from interactive tell thank
you Dan
if we can go back to the slides please
interactive tell provides services that
capture and analyze business
communications a lot of the data we
collect is audio from the recording of
phone calls we have clients that
accumulate a quarter of a million
minutes and one month of conversations
to put that in perspective it would take
one person a hundred and seventy three
days of continuous listening to review
every call now normally those recordings
would just sit there until something
happened that caused a particular
conversation to come under scrutiny when
that conversation went under scrutiny it
may be because of a disgruntled customer
or even a lawsuit services like the ones
that I'll show you today transfer
information from a phone call to CRM
companies to lead and contact management
systems and even to managers in the form
of a text message when something goes
wrong we're able to provide this value
by translating speech into text using
cloud speech API and provide value to
our clients since the new services we
were able to provide we've been able to
add 75 new accounts in 30 days and over
2,100 new opportunities just from these
new services
let's talk a little bit about the
architecture that we use from our
telephony infrastructure we streamed
speech in real time the Google's cloud
speech API we take the results we got
from Google and then pass them through
our analysis engine which extracts
sentiment keywords and key phrases all
or which are used to construct an
understanding of what's happening on a
call
we take our findings and then publish
them to CRM companies our data
visualization tools and other
subscribers they take that information
and then pass it along to managers who
can intervene if necessary and analyze
the data to see what's happening if we
can go to the laptop now
I'm going to share with you a video of
exactly what happens in a dealership
when this technology is in use thank you
for calling ABC motors this is Jack how
may I help you hi I'm calling about a
car I saw advertised on your website
it's the 2017 blue sedan that was fired
by John Davis yes
we've received several calls on that car
it's really one of a kind let me take
down your number in case we get
disconnected I'll call you back I don't
mean to be rude but I don't worried
about my number I'm just interested in
car can you tell me if it's still
available let me go put my hands on to
be sure please hold
I also came up with a nice demonstration
for you guys which is gonna require some
participation sure is on your part
so our specialty is new business
communications capturing an analysis so
we thought it would be pretty cool for
this demo to have members of the
audience call a number which represents
the telephony portion and we tie in to
Google Cloud speech API will ask you
where you're from you mentioned your
country city state or what have you and
we'll plot that on the map so the number
that's on the screen 201 340 800 for any
willing participant out there if you
pick up your cell phone make that call
you'll be prompted for to say where
you're from and hopefully we'll get
enough participation that we'll start
getting some blips up there on the map
so if you will please to make some calls
that's pretty cool
so this is using G RPC to stream
real-time while you guys are on the
phone and you'll notice a lot of names
are popping up there we're doing reverse
phone to pen to also attach additional
value what's also interesting about this
particular mashup is if you don't say a
city or state and you say a particular
company if that company is you know has
a presence on Google Maps that would
also show a dot there we'll leave this
up for probably for the rest of the day
so if anybody was savvy enough to copy
the URL the phone number this demo will
be active for the remainder of the day
I'm gonna transition into the code
behind behind this particular demo it's
very similar to what Dan showed earlier
[Music]
effectively you know this is the
left-knee code where we're playing
greetings recording the file locally and
the transcribe function is very
transcribed file function is very
similar to the one that Dan showed
earlier of course we've enabled the
profanity filter to make the results
less interesting
if we can go back to the slides please
we did have some technical challenges
when implementing cloud speech API the
first of which was timestamps and I
don't know if any of you were here are
part of the user groups but that's a
topic that came up quite frequently many
phone calls were 15 minutes or longer in
length and an important part of our user
experience is allowing a person to click
on a key word or phrase and skip ahead
to a phone conversation to the point at
which that word or phrase was spoken
currently cloud speech API does not
provide timestamps when we did devise a
way to implement them that works for us
the way we did this is is as follows we
pre process audio to detect silence in
between words phrases we then use that
detected silence to segment the file and
submit those segments individually to
cloud API the responses we get back we
associate with the segment and the
interval at which we detect it and it
allows us to know that for instance
segment a which comprised the first
eight tenths of the of the conversation
was the word Google we repeat that
process for each word or phrase and the
recording and enables us to construct a
transcription of exactly what happened
on the call and the time in which it
occurred another issue we ran into a
speaker Dyer ization as we're you know
telephony company we have two sides of
the conversation cloud speech wasn't
really designed initially for this type
of conversation so we record our files
in Styria which gives us a caller on one
channel and the colleague on the other
now if we were to take that audio file
and separate them into two channels we'd
end up with one minute of audio one
minute of phone call and two minutes of
audio one minute for the left side one
minute for the right effectively
doubling our cost for processing a
stereo file
in order to mitigate that we expanded
our pre-processing algorithm to detect
large stands of silence we then remove
that silence from the audio and submit
the segment's individually keeping track
of whether that was submitted for the
left side or the right side of the
converse of conversation we then
reconstruct the transcription using the
method that I showed you earlier
associating segments with time intervals
but also associating them with the
caller or collie our experience with
loud speech API has been pretty awesome
I learned to turn yesterday which is
dark data and for us recordings and
probably a lot of you that may have
audio that that happens today and
recording for a Matt it's just dark data
you don't know what's going on there
well using cloud speech API we were able
to shed light on our recordings and I
like to thank you for allowing me to
share that experience with you if you
can stay on stage I actually have a
question for you so could you talk a
little bit about so once you transcribe
these phone calls
like for example that scenario that you
showed in the video where customer is
calling about a car that's not in stock
sort of what do you guys do in terms of
that analytics in terms of the workflow
what how do you provide value to car
dealerships that's a great question so
example is you see a car on the website
you call in and for whatever reason that
car is not available this particular
dealership is using our system so we
know exactly what's happening on the
call and the automotive space they have
a notion of everybody that calls in you
want to get their contact information
their name their number product of
interests so that if that product does
become available because it's a very
fluid market you have a point of contact
to reach the reach back out to them so
we identified key factors number one the
call was for sales number two there was
a product that they were interested in
and number three there was no contact
information that was collected in our
space we call that a missed opportunity
and which becomes actionable because
we'll send that to a sales manager in
the form of a text message and or an
email based on his settings to let him
know that this particular opportunity
may have been missed what ends up
happening in those cases large
dealerships have this instance occurring
you know dozens of times a week and it
really impacts their bottom line to be
able to have a second chance at selling
that particular customer so what if what
have been reactions for dealerships that
have tried the new system well the
reaction has been overwhelmingly
positive
in fact large dealer groups are that
we've demoed and and had an opportunity
to to show our system to end up pushing
it out throughout their whole group I
don't know if I'm allowed to mention
customer names or I mean if you can just
say you're like in terms of business
value or like like are they actually
making more sales or is this just like a
nice-to-have
well not only are they making more sales
but it's causing a shift in the
mentality at car dealerships because now
everyone in the dealership is being held
accountable it's one thing to have a
recording or monitoring solution in
place and people know it's there but
that's reactive meaning the only time
that that information is ever going to
be leveraged is if there's a situation
that calls that into question you know
whereas using cloud speech we're able to
mine these these conversations for
actionable intelligence to allow us to
empower dealers to be proactive and
provide a higher level of customer
service and it's really becoming
disruptive in our industry great awesome
you cannot you can stay here I just have
two more slides and then we can do Q&A
so I just want to give you guys a plug
for two more sessions that are that are
happening you know a little bit after
this one in about 30 40 minutes one is
sensitive data management so you get all
this text coming back from speech API a
lot of it is going to contain PII you
know a lot of customers have asked us
what can we do about
that and so if you note if you saw the
keynote today they spoke about a new
product that we just announced this
morning called data loss prevention
we're going to talk more about that
product in this session room 30 25 20
and then for those of you that are
interested in building conversational
applications and connecting to Google
assistant you know that there's a lot of
overlap there with speech recognition
there's there's a session that's gonna
dive deep into that right in this room
actually at 5:20 so those are their two
upcoming sessions with that let's go do
a Q&A
[Music]
you